President Biden's personal attorney, Bob
Bauer, released a statement
in just the last a little over an hour
saying that the Justice Department
conducted a search of the Wilmington,
Delaware, home
and found additional materials
with classified markings.
Now, Bauer
stresses that this search
was done in coordination
with the president's personal attorneys.
Both the personal attorneys
and lawyers
from the White House
counsel's office were on hand
for that search.
A source has also told us
that it was specifically
conducted by the FBI.
And what Bauer said
is that they opened up the home
for this search
that included a search of the living,
the working and the storage areas.
And Wilmington, Delaware.
And I want to read
you a bit of his statement
that gets into exactly
what types of materials
they were looking through.
Bauer wrote in a statement, quote,
DOJ had full access
to the president's
home, including personally handwritten
notes, filed papers, binders, memorabilia
to do lists, schedules
and reminders going back decades.
DOJ took possession of materials
it deemed within the scope
of its inquiry,
including six items
consisting of document
with classification markings
and surrounding materials.
Some of which were from the president's
service in the Senate
and some of which were from his tenure
as vice president.
DOJ also took for further
review personally handwritten notes
from the vice presidential years.
Now, the White House
special counsel,
Richard Saber,
said that neither
President Biden nor First Lady
Jill Biden were on hand
for this search yesterday,
which took close to 13 hours.
But really,
this marks
the fifth instance that we know of
where documents
were found to either
locations tied to President Biden.
There was first
that discovery
on November 2nd
at the Penn
Biden Center,
that private office
Biden used when he left
the Obama administration.
There was another search
conducted in Wilmington, Delaware,
on December 20th
and then also another on January 11th.
And the following day,
more documents were found but yesterday
did amount to the fifth time
the documents had been found at locations
tied to President Biden.
Of course,
it wasn't until much later
after that
initial search on November 2nd.
It wasn't until two months later
that it was revealed
that those documents had even been found
publicly to this press.
But this all comes
as the White House
has been grappling with this ongoing saga
related to the classified documents.
And one thing
that they've faced
some criticism over
is their initial unwillingness
to disclose
the finding of these documents
right away.
And I want to
have you listen to
what President Biden
had to say earlier this week
when he was asked
whether he had any regrets
about their decisions not to
disclose things right away.
That revealed
back in December before the big time this
law
as we found out,
we found a handful
of documents were failed,
were filed in the wrong place.
We're fully cooperating.
Looking forward
to getting this resolved quickly.
I think you're going to find there's
nothing there.
I have no regrets.
I'm following
what the lawyers have told me.
They want me to do
exactly what we're doing.
There's no they're there.
Of course,
this is a remarkable
string of events
that has unfolded over
the course of the past two weeks.
And now with the FBI
searching the home of a current
sitting president, of course,
the White House
has been quick
to point out
that they are trying to cooperate
fully every step of the way
with the special counsel's investigation,
with the Justice Department,
with the National Archives.
Of course,
they're trying to draw this contrast
with the way that former
President Donald Trump
handled the classified documents
down in Mar
a Lago as he is being investigated
down there for obstruction.
But the White House trying to make clear
that they are trying to follow each step
that the Justice Department
has laid out for them
and cooperate in this matter.
But at this moment,
just yesterday, more documents were found
at that
Wilmington, Delaware,
home, bringing the total
known classified documents
found between the home
and then also that private office
to close to 30.
I will also note
that President Biden
is currently spending the weekend here
in Rehoboth
Beach, Delaware, with his wife, Dr.
Jill Biden.
The personal attorney has had said
that the
Rehoboth Beach home had been searched
just last week
and now the couple is spending
this weekend here.
You have searched
by the personal attorneys,
and we do expect
FBI agents to search other properties
connected to Joe Biden. Arlette.
Thank you.
What a night
they are in Rehoboth Beach, Delaware.
She is traveling with the president.
This is an extraordinary development.
We have a number of experts
to help us better understand
what this all means, including CNN senior
legal affairs correspondent Paula Reid.
She is on the phone.
And we also have national security
attorney Mark
Zaid,
former federal prosecutor Michael Zeldin
and arm governor,
professor,
a lecturer in law at law at George
Washington University.
Thank you all for coming on March eight.
I want to start with you.
You have a lot of experience
dealing with classified documents
and so forth.
What do you make of this
latest development?
Six more classified documents found
at the president's residence
and how could this
impact the investigation?
Well, it's embarrassing.
I mean, let's put it plain and simple.
This has been mishandled
from from day one.
I'm not concerned
even with the discovery of additional
possibly classified documents,
because just because they're still marked
classified from
however many years ago
doesn't mean
the information is still classified.
We'll have to find out.
It doesn't excuse it.
I don't think
it will impact the legal case involving
President Biden for a number of reasons,
which we can go into.
But this is obviously politically
going to be fodder for the Republicans.
And more importantly,
unfortunately, it could, though
it shouldn't
as a matter of law, impact
how the Justice Department deals
with President Trump,
because as you've been saying,
so many people
are trying to make a comparison
that this is apples and apples
when it's not even close.
The two situations
are completely factually distinct.
The bottom line, though,
and you're
absolutely right,
there are key distinctions.
Most of all,
there is an obstruction investigation
with Trump where evidence was developed.
Documents have been moved
to other places.
And in fact,
when that search warrant was
executed, they did find
several classified documents.
I think it was around 100,
if my memory serves me at Mar a Lago.
But that aside, in this case,
you have a sitting president's
personal residence being searched
by the FBI for nearly 13 hours.
This is truly extraordinary.
It's historic.
And in terms
of the national security implications,
you say, Marc,
you don't believe that this
this is going to have
serious implications on that front.
But armed the war.
What would prosecutors be looking at?
They're going to
take these classified documents.
They're going to look at everything
that they've gathered
through the course of this investigation.
Walk us through the process
of what they're looking for
to see if laws had been broken here.
Pamela, thank you so
much for having me on.
So at the base,
this is
deeply embarrassing to the president
and I think a big distinguishing factor
that's
unfortunate for the president
is that he's in the hot seat right now.
Right.
So this is
this is not good in terms of the process.
Robert Herr, who is just appointed
by Attorney General Garland,
is appropriately, as I understand, it,
from the facts that we all have together
using the FBI,
Federal Bureau of Investigation
to do the investigation,
which which he must there.
The fact gathers.
It appears,
from what
I've read,
the same access information
that you have,
that this is something
that was collaborative
and there was cooperation
on the part
of the president and his attorneys.
And it's going to take a very long time.
It's a very carefully and meticulously
and rigorously goes
through the information
to see that a crime,
whether a crime was committed.
And it's indeed one was
it's still ultimately going to be
the attorney general of the United
States, the next to call
So we know that six
more documents
with classified
markings were taken,
including other information,
Michael Zeldin.
And they mentioned handwritten letters.
They mentioned materials.
And we don't know if those were
classified materials
or not from Biden's time as service.
What would additional materials
be on those with classified markings?
How would they help investigators
in this investigation?
Why would they be pertinent here?
So the FBI and the special counsel
are investigating
what is a mishandling of documents
case now.
And that question is
were these documents mishandled?
The answer is yes.
Why were they mishandled?
Was that intentional or unintentional
that's being inquired of?
Were they
disseminated to anybody
while they were mishandled?
That's another question that they ask.
So they have to answer these
particular questions
to make a determination
whether or not
is mishandling of classified documents
rises to the level of a criminal charge
or whether it's inadvertent
and therefore not criminal
in terms of
what's in the documents themselves.
That remains to be seen.
But I remember him
when I did the indictment,
my independent counsel investigation,
and we interviewed
former President George Herbert
Walker Bush in his offices in Houston.
We said to him, Mr.
President,
do you have any recollection of this?
He said, well, let me go check my diary.
And he went out, came
back, came back with his diary.
He said, No,
I have no indication of that,
but I do have an indication of this.
So here's a present for president
with a diary in his personal office.
Which probably had classification issues
that surround them.
So I don't think
that is in and of itself significant,
but it is
what the prosecutors need to ascertain
before they can make a determination
about whether something
is classified or not.
To what Mark said, though,
and I think needs
reiterating is these document cases
point to the fact
that there is overclassification
in the United States government
and that there are so many documents
that shouldn't be classified,
that are classified.
That gets politicians
who are unintentional
in their handling
these documents,
but sloppy in these sort of legal jams.
And I think that one of the things
that Congress should be doing is looking
at the classification system.